[Applause]
[Music]
heidi klum changes the life of a lucky
contestant on america's got talent you
know dreams do come true pushing her
golden buzzer for singer-songwriter lily
mayola as heidi later shared to twitter
she can't wait for the world to fall in
love with her let's dive into this
emotional moment what's your name please
my name is lily mayola i'm a
singer-songwriter during her intro the
mood quickly turns serious as lily
explains the backstory of the original
song she's performing i
wrote it a time in my life when things
were really beautiful and then my life
flipped upside down and
my mom was diagnosed with cancer
and i became her full-time caretaker she
passed away i'm sorry lily heidi is
clearly moved by her story and then
watches the magic of lily's performance
as it inspires tears and brings the
audience to their feet
[Applause]
[Music]
the judges praised lily's audition with
heidi sharing a passionate reaction i
don't know what to say i'm like
speechless you just light up i see a
light around you and i don't know i like
immediately i fell in love with you
and that's when heidi makes her daydream
come true
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
the golden buzzer is an important
feature on america's got town as it fast
tracks contestants to the next round as
the judges tell et those moments are
when the show is at its best i got to
say something so uh do you know what the
golden buzzer is right the golden buzzer
is that ticket that that just makes our
hearts explode i just feel that i am so
happy they told me that that golden
buzzer changed their lives and get this
right before lily's big moment heidi
revealed she actually wasn't rooting for
a singer in this year's auditions i was
like there's always a lot of singers on
the stage and i was like i want to give
someone else a shot
but i can't help it because i really
really like you but leading up to the
season premiere heidi says that talent
is talent and the variety is what makes
her job special a lot of comedians this
year
a lot of goofy kind of acts too where
we're like
why did we just let this person through
but we had the best time so sometimes
we're just you know because sometimes we
see people doing weird things that we've
never seen before and we're like well
let's give this a chance you know and
let's see where this is gonna go like
let's see what they have next
but it's a mixed bag of
fun weird sometimes sad you know it's
really the emotions go up and down
[Music]
you